hello reza ferruja welcome to the studio
congratulations on the performance on
this tournament did you see yourself
coming to saint louis playing in this
dream club for you especially how the
gct had started and coming out with the
victory in the grand chess tour
yeah it's a really
amazing feeling um when i came to saint
louis i was in last almost last place in
gct so
i played very bad in romania but okay i
played decent in croatia so
but in general i am happy with how
things went i could have improved my
result maybe a bit more
for instance game against john but okay
he played brilliantly so
um i cannot be very bad very sad about
that so
i'm in general happy with the play and
yeah it's really amazing that i could
play at uh
i i'm really happy that i could play at
my best here in saint louis you mean
right yeah it's an amazing city um must
be one of your favorite places in the
world now
it was before i come so
um it's really amazing whenever i walk
around the club
it's really everything is very high
class in this area
and the club is just amazing so
um it's really
privileged to be here well the privilege
is ours to see your tournament
performances here tell us what some of
the highlights that you remember from
this grand chess tour
um yes um yeah of course the highlight
is here in saint louis
the other places i are not very special
but especially here in san luis i won a
very important tournament the rapid and
blitz one
and that was a very
great boost for me
to start with things well here
and
yeah in general the grand chester is the
toughest tour in the history of chess i
think so
to win it is an amazing
feeling and
[Music]
i cannot be more happy
it seems that things started clicking
you coming here did you do any kind of
special preparation or something that
changed the way that you started to play
yeah i i i
for sure i got some experience from the
candidates tournament
i played their
14 games very imp very tough games
against very good players
and everybody was motivated so i'm
so i took a lot of
lessons there and experiences there and
it definitely helped me to be
at the top of my game here so
and in general um i think the rapid and
blitz portion i played very well
and that really gave me confidence for
the classical because it's really
a boost so
in general i think the candidates
tournament helped me a lot of course
let's go back to that point you said
that the candidates tournament was a
lesson for you what did you learn what
went wrong over for you in madrid
yeah there were many things that they
were
wrong um
okay it's part of
chess chess
related some part is not just related
but
um there are many things that
still still i am learning still i'm
going back and thinking about it
maybe in my team we should have made
some different
um adjustments but in general
i think
for the first time in being in the
candidates it really helped me to get
experience if nobody was
expecting me to okay maybe rating was
like was one of the favorite but
um in general it's a very tough
tournament you need to have a lot of
experience so for instance like like
fabiano he had a lot of experience he
won it
i don't know two times and he still
collapsed at the end so it just shows
how difficult it is the tournament
absolutely very difficult tournament
you are one of the youngest people here
at the top you've now won the gct at
only 19 you crossed 2 800. what's next
yes for now um
i i want to improve my rating of course
and
it's really important for me for the
rating i think
to go hop is very important to go at
least back to 2800
um i lost it very
you know because i was not in a good
shape and lost the rating a lot and
now i should go back and train more and
see what's coming up next so
yeah peter joined the conversation yeah
jessie winner yeah just one question for
you all and raising first of all our
congratulations
simply an outstanding performance salute
i mean no question about it thanks but
but
your tournament may not be over
is a very strong possibility that you
would have a playoff against nepo first
of all have you been involved in
playoffs in the past and if so how did
you do and then finally
how about nepo
would you like to play it at play i have
never been in the playoffs um one time i
had the chance to go was the world rapid
and blitz this last year but the rules
were not the same as grand cheese tour
so
i was third place and first and second
they played the playoffs so yeah
there i lost my chance but yeah i never
played any playoff in my life so
maybe in some
strange tournaments five six years ago
but not in a top level tournament so
and uh but i think jan has a good chance
to win today so do you like his position
we can take a look it's a very good
position i think this end game is known
to be better for white there are some
good games that white won
and senia here takes e4 bishop b5 it
really
you look at the board real quick yeah
right over here we take bishop takes e4
we show v6 bishop b5 bishop d7 i guess
yeah i think if you go bishop d7 you're
worse i think he probably should maybe
try to castle immediately ah yes just
play wow with this shatter structure
yeah if of course void consolidates here
is it he's much better but okay there
the king will be attacked with f5 right
yeah f5 from d4 hd8 yeah something like
this right yeah i have a feeling maybe
hans knows this position he's thinking
but i think he analyzed this position
maybe
because it looks very direct the
way he's playing so
and of course jan has to go for this
position because otherwise there's
nothing to play for
so it's a very direct position maybe
yeah it's tricky of course i cannot say
jan will win this game for sure but he
has a good chance here of course i want
to ask you about your opponents in the
grand chess tour is there any anybody in
particular that's given you a lot of
trouble
um yes of course wesley is a very good
player um every year he plays
okay i never played in granchester it's
my first time but every year i watch
he plays always very well and he's
always in the top fighting for the
first place so he's very good i think he
was my biggest
competitor of course but jan is also a
great player but somehow he didn't
perform and performed very well in grand
chester so
but he's amazing player of course
and this is a good time for you to pay
attention to the monitors i'm being told
let's take a look at what they have
prepared for you
i guess that's official
grandmaster aladesa farouza the 2022 gct
champion comes with a extra hundred
thousand dollars not bad congratulations
thank you
yeah well well played and uh i mean not
much to add i i just for me personally
there was this this little mention of i
want to at least get back to 2800 i'm
just sitting here thinking yeah you know
small steps you know
i was like little little targets
you shouldn't really set yourself too
ambitious a target in life just at least
get back to 2800 of course it's very
difficult to get to 2800 because there
are not many 2800s nowadays so i have to
play always with
lower player low rated players and it's
very difficult but okay i have to try it
well it is a pity when you have to play
these lower rated players like bobby and
nepo and wesley and the wing nipple is
higher than me
i like how he knows that very
specifically there's a congratulations
we'll let you watch the rest of the
games in case that you need a playoff
and we might see you later today thank
you
again our congratulations indeed
absolutely i just uh